there was four things that I pulled from
the notes that I thought were truly
truly the most transformative things for
me in my life that I still used to today
so I thought we'd go through them and
you could explain them and explain like
what it means and how to access it and
and just sort of the the origins of
these uh of these thoughts so the first
one is uh the Observer like being able
to access the Observer and to pause and
have that moment so explain to people
what is the Observer and how the hell do
we get there yeah I love the Observer
it's you know I think the Observer
actually bursts from
the witnessing component to what I talk
about in the book so so first like The
Observer to to almost step out of being
in this moment this experience this
conflict that you're having this big
reaction that you're experiencing and
it's in that pause um it's been
attributed to to Victor Frankel
um that that space between you know
stimulus and response right and so it's
in this space right where we can where
if we can just take the beat right pause
for a moment and become the Observer of
what's happening in my inner world right
now right what's going on because in
that space we start to be able to ask
ourselves the questions like what's
familiar about this moment you know what
what what origin wound is this rubbing
up against
um I often say as adults it's very
uncommon for us to have a first
experience in terms of emotion
it's not uncommon to have a first
experience of you know content and
context something that's happening in
our lives but when it rubs up against
ooh I'm starting to question my
worthiness I'm starting to question my
belonging I'm starting to question
whether I feel like a priority in
somebody's life I'm starting to question
whether I can trust this person this
situation or I'm starting to to question
whether or not I feel safe in this
Dynamic right it's like those things
which are the origin wounds I talk about
in in the book it's like that's what's
familiar and so when we can become the
observer in these moments where there's
a big reactivity there's a pattern that
I keep finding myself in and I need to
become
curious and you know get get into the
inquiry of what's actually being
presented here we're going to find
something something that links to
something else that is unresolved about
our past not really about the thing
happening it's about the thing inside
you yeah I mean it's like you've heard
this before right like therapists around
the world are like it's not about the
toilet seat it's not about the towel on
the bed it's not about third yeah right
like all of these things which sure
objectively sometimes are quite annoying
sometimes we're like no no I promise
it's about the towel on the bed I'm like
listen I get it right and there is also
something additional that's playing out
here those are kind of the systemic the
systemic sort of reactions yes to the
origin like this is the hard part I
think because it's like all in theory
it's great access the Observer have a
pause but we aren't freaking Buddhas
right and we're not on a mountain we've
got stimulus happening all the time
what is some ways that we can Orient
ourselves
differently in the world on a macro
level that gives us the ability to have
a pause because it's not not knowing
that a pause is good everybody knows a
pause is good problem is you can't it's
it's very hard when you get the stimulus
or you get the trigger so like what is
it that comes first before you can
actually become an observer
what I would say is to practice when
you're not in the stimulus right so a
lot of times we try to practice when you
know that we're on stage and it's like
nope can't do it already activated you
pissed off in the loop ready to go and
like we're out right and so so much of
the inquiry and the Curiosity it's
really helpful when we're doing that
work when we're
feeling grounded when we're just in a
place of questioning and wanting to get
to know these parts of ourselves better
when we're not actually in that hot seat
you're right when we're when we're in it
and we don't have the you know we're
trying to practice the tools but the
tools are out the window before we even
know it it can feel like it's it's a
pointless uh path to go down the second
thing that I would say though is one of
the things that helped me so much
personally was that the more that I
witnessed and grieved my own pain the
less likely I would need to hook into
the pattern or The Loop when it when it
was trying to play itself out even when
the stimulus was happening so what I
mean by that is
when I when you can identify what the
origin wound is right so again whether
that's I don't feel worthy I don't feel
deserving I don't feel good enough
whether it's I don't feel like I fit in
I don't have a sense of belonging I
don't feel like a priority to my partner
et cetera Etc right when we can actually
see like oh here's the thing that
activates me and then if I connect my
dots and I travel backwards a bit I'm
gonna probably find that that lived
somewhere else too right maybe I didn't
feel like a priority with a parent
um maybe I didn't feel like a priority
with a sibling right maybe that was
something that was deeply impactful for
me
and so when we go back into this origin
space and we begin to actually process
and feel and connect and witness the
pain of that because usually those
origin wounds they do cut deep right
they're not just like a brush you know
it's like no these are things that
actually change the trajectory of Our
Lives of our worlds of our beliefs about
ourself ourselves and other people and
life at large right these are
significant moments that set the stage
for us and so when we go back to those
moments and we actually witness the
little Vienna in this case right who was
The Observer and the witnesser of a
tremendous amount of conflict and
gaslighting and manipulation and
paranoia and abuse as a little girl uh
through through my parents divorce right
like oh and I get to witness her and
what it was like for this little human
had no other siblings who didn't have
any other adults around to help her
process this right then I start to
connect with you know the part of me
that that didn't feel emotionally safe
right where I felt like they had lost
focus of what my emotional needs were at
that time because you know they were so
distracted by their own pain and their
own suffering right right and so when
you can start to connect to that to
grieve alongside of it I always say like
when in doubt grieve more you know it's
like when stuck grieve more like
anything grieve more you know it's like
yeah our experiences need our grief and
my personal experience with this is that
the more time that I spent with little
me you know the more time I spent
connecting to that pain the more time I
spent
um witnessing what that was like for
little me the less I needed to engage in
the dysfunction present day
because I was tending to myself
elsewhere so instead of trying to get
whomever right whether it's a parent or
someone else to witness or see or
acknowledge me in this current moment
right there was almost like a
like a emotional bank account of I've
done I'm doing the witnessing I've done
the witnessing I have a great partner
who sees me hears me understand it is
this true like a comment that comes
through and like repeated like when you
see the little little girl or little boy
within you it's the innocence and the
Perfection and you see you have it's
it's something separate from you but
it's still treating it like it's
separate from you is still treating you
and so you'd never treat your kid like
that you'd never say you don't belong
you'd never say you're not worthy so it
almost like accesses the is this really
true kind of a question yeah right and
it and it disrupts that because that's
what we're talking about with this you
know going back to your original
question around you know how sure the
observer in theory is great but in
practice and I think it's when you are
tending to yourself or you invite in
humans in your life who tend to you well
whether friendship partnership Etc right
then you are less likely and less in
need of engaging in the dance that you
know is not going to go very well with a
particular person right like you don't
need to hook into that dysfunctional
pattern right this Loop
um and tending to yourself or having
other humans who can witness intend I
say it in the book like there's this
moment
um I was talking to a family member or
the conversation was going in the same
way that it always goes it was on
speakerphone at the time my husband was
in the room and after we hung up he said
I get it you know I I in so many words
he was validating an experience that I
had you know complained about
um for some time I remember it was such
a simple but really profound moment for
me because I realized that I didn't need
the person who
put the wound there in the first place
to be the person who witnessed my pain
that's nice if we can get it certainly
of course but I remember this deeply
profound moment of like it doesn't have
to be that person yeah
right and
again like in theory might sound like
yeah of course right but I think so many
of us especially in family Dynamics
family systems like there's this wish
there's this deep want and need right
that a parent might be able to
acknowledge and
you know
just acknowledge your pain right or just
acknowledge your experience or just take
ownership for something that you really
want them to own and so sometimes we get
so caught up in it I've had so many
conversations with people it's like well
maybe if I say it this way or maybe if I
write a letter if maybe I use this tone
or maybe yeah
number two that was literally the most
transformative thing that you said to me
do you know what it was can you remember
no I don't know what it was well you
talked to hours hours and hours
thousands of people
um I don't expect you to but it's
probably because it's so second nature
to you but it's when you told me that
day after I was complaining about all
the things and Dad and parents and and
you were like nobody holds the keys and
I was like
buck
because I I think the first thing I said
was I was like whoa and I started crying
and I was like that's really heavy
because that means that
it's all on me like it's I don't know if
I said it's my fault but I'm like
essentially alone and figuring that out
and you're like no you're not you have
me you have people you don't have to do
it alone but it is up to you it's like I
say now it's like your wounds are not
your fault but they are your
responsibility to heal if you like this
clip and you want to hear the whole
episode click at the bottom of your
screen